sécurité routière à présent mercredi
suite à la mort d'un motard non loin de
Versailles des contrôles routiers ont
été renforcés durant le week-end de
l'Ascension c'est le deuxième motard qui
trouve la mort sur nos routes depuis le
début de l'année des effectifs de police
se sont donc déployés dans tout le
département pour faire de la prévention
routière le contrôle systématique des
deux roues est un événement rare écouté
les explications de ce déploiement
spécifique au micro de Michael Ali
midoro c'est un détail très important
comme la météo par exemple aujourd'hui
et ces derniers jours poussent tout au
bon nombre de motocyclistes à prendre la
route donc certains sont chevronnés et
roule tout l'hiver mais quand même
relativement peu et le danger c'est
souvent les les jeunes conducteurs ou
alors les conducteurs qui ne roulent pas
forcément toute l'année qui se mettent à
cette saison à rouler on est un peu
euphorique il fait beau etc et le danger
se rapproche beaucoup plus vite quoi